so if you have high blood pressure
you're probably not totally excited
about some of the side effects that are
occurring with high blood pressure
medication so you're probably looking
for something more natural and of course
check with your doctor before
implementing what i'm going to tell you
but as you
research to find the underlying cause
i'm going to give you a really good
solution to help bring down your blood
pressure in the meantime that has
virtually no side effects
of all
hypertension is called essential
hypertension now what is essential
hypertension it basically is a type of
hypertension that has
an unknown cause they don't know what
causes it okay
well i'm going to give my viewpoint on
that most people with high blood
pressure okay either have a potassium
deficiency
which will cause high blood pressure
very fast
or they're low in vitamin d
okay
now both of these are very common and a
lot of people have them
and if someone's on a high carb diet
they're probably going to create a
potassium deficiency as well as a
vitamin d deficiency just
by the nature of what happens to the
receptor for insulin so there's also
this high insulin factor from a high
carb diet that creates
stiffened arteries that then lead to
high blood pressure
you can also get high blood pressure
from stress and high levels of cortisol
as well but i'm just talking about the
the main things that cause high blood
pressure if you're low in potassium your
arteries get stiff so potassium helps to
make your arteries nice and supple and
flexible and elastic
if you're low in vitamin d which by the
way it's not really a vitamin it's a
steroid
and it works with other hormones
you can also develop problems within the
inside layer of the artery which then
can trigger
higher amounts of pressure so there's a
great solution
when i say drink one cup i'm really
saying drink
a very large cup okay because
this
recipe of things i'm going to tell you
about
exceed just one little cup but here's
what i'm going to recommend to put in
this cup and you're going to first
blend everything except this right here
flaxseed you'll grind it and you'll just
take two teaspoons and you'll grind
flaxseed now why flaxseed flaxseed has
compounds that give very potent
hypertensive properties so it helps to
lower blood pressure plus it's very high
in something called ala this is a
precursor to
epa and dha which are the omega-3 fatty
acids so it can help restore artery
function okay so we're going to grind
two teaspoons of flax seed put it in the
blender
number two celery
celery has something in it called
phthalides okay
and this compound
not only helps you lower blood pressure
but it also helps you sleep so if you
get some organic celery take two stalks
maybe cut it up a little bit stick it in
that blender
all right number three avocado why
avocado is a food that has
a huge amount of potassium and so we
want to somehow spike the potassium in
this drink so you would do about a half
of an avocado you can put the whole
thing in there if you want but half will
be sufficient too
because we're going to be drinking this
each day
at the meal not an empty stomach okay
number four lemon juice you can do the
juice of one lemon or do one ounce of
lemon juice okay pour it right in the
blender lemon juice has some significant
research
that can help someone with high blood
pressure and i'm going to put all that
down below
number five blueberries now of course
blueberries are going to actually offset
the taste of this shake
but blueberries by themself have
anti-hypertensive
properties okay and i'm going to put
that research down below too
just stick a half a cup in there
blueberries out of all the berries have
the most sugar so don't go crazy with
too much but
one half of a cup will be fine okay so
we put those in there and then we add
some plain kefir which also has
antihypertensive properties
from a different angle half a cup of
that
and then we're going to add a cup of
water and you're going to blend this for
about one minute okay it's going to make
this nice creamy drink and you're going
to slug it down and i would recommend
consuming this right after your meal the
combination of all these six things
will definitely bring that blood
pressure down real nicely without the
side effects as you start getting your
diet under control and you fix your
insulin resistance to the point where
you don't need any help because it's
it's normalized now if you haven't seen
my other video on the tea that you can
drink to lower your blood pressure i'm
going to put that up right here check it
out